[Music]
more
what
e e
uh let's look at the principle okay so
in in in
Kori cross you you always going to
have cuz you always should is this angle
of
cancellation okay so the angle
cancellation is that it's going to draw
a diagonal through his three planes so
depth it's pull it's going this way okay
and then height there's some lower
lowering to it and then obviously width
there's some horizontal to it okay so
we're here for example you
see not our technique this
way you have to get that angle
cancellation first it has to go through
all three zones okay what that does is
that sets up a zon Sanctuary momentarily
where you can enter
without his weapons both facing you you
see that side of his body those weapons
are on the other side of this
side this side was being directly
impacted by the angle cancellation and
then I've smothered them as I'm doing
this movement this is where this is
where I am okay so there'd be downward
pressure on that leg from the
pull with my body here with my head in
front and my shoulder in the back it
can't really turn towards me okay so
there's width pressure and then because
I'm at the angle when I start to dry I'm
attacking the depth from that same zone
of sanctuary you guys as opposed to your
here your front this is even even
there's no Advantage here so you want an
angal cancellation through his three
zones and then you want to be at an
angle to his spine line you don't want
to be in front of him you want to
capitalize upon the Zone Sanctuary that
you generated from the angle
cancellation okay so the arm drag like
all codori techniques does that so he
goes he he's he's coming in he goes for
that grab and there's the arm drag right
here I pull it I'm in that
position you tries the neck pank same
thing I go this way boom there it is
right there and I'm in that position
again he does the cross gra it's already
there that's easy that's just light out
of keyone you're in that position again
okay
um what else were you guys facing so the
two I got two choices here I can go to
this arm drag right or I can take this
one and sha and take that arm Dr and I'm
in that same position okay but what I'm
not doing is going here and stay in here
and all that kind of
stuff I can move I don't want I don't
like what's going on there I can move
but once he goes to get it I go right
into that position whatever it is once
you goes to get it I go right into that
position then you'll find the single leg
okay without fighting right no
contesting okay try it again just those
so he goes there's that one I go here
and I'm close drive drive at me drive
I'm ground vectoring do you see just
just exactly like that your ground
Vector just here he's driving your
ground vectoring okay and then you
move so you can't be same one please you
can't be way out here you you I can't
move I'm going to have to step and then
get and he's going to be gone so you set
it up one and then
project whichever one you want one close
enough drive drive this is where I'm at
and I
too far out too far out I have no Ed in
me back foot here here's where I ground
and this is where D five this is what I
push okay all right try it not too hard
he goes boom in drrive
catch boom drve catch
then when you do the second one you
catch you have to drive again okay it's
the same exact way so you're going to
you're come this way I'm going to do it
one time okay you you're stuck you're
stuck move your leg wherever you want
you're stuck to it you keep non
contesting it okay just cuz my hand here
doesn't mean I'm doing this I'm just
stuck to it and then you project that
leg just like if you going to throw him
you're projecting and that's what you
catch cuz you're stuck to it so one
drive
never
here here no
drive light catch
project catch easy
peasy okay try